features that hark back to the olden
days but this isn't a well-preserved
classic it's a soapbox replica built in
2017 and the proud possession of sisters
urea and Cullotta has
[Music]
we think it's cool that we as kids are
allowed to drive a car even if it's a
small car it's a lot of fun or in Smash
bash bass I think it's great too because
it's fun and it's always a new
experience this soapbox even has a motor
the girls two-seater is handmade and
one-of-a-kind it's a remake of the
English 1930s Lagonda rocky and it's
pretty much their dads dream car dad
Kutztown is a big fan of classic cars
and he's aiming to pass on his passion
to urea and Coolatta from his schools
I'm very hopeful and I take my girls to
classic car races at the Nurburgring
sometimes they take part in rallies
along with me and my wife they'll make
their father's hobby their own embassy
does so be this fat herself to complete
your name then the two girls soon
squabbled over this homage to the
Bugatti 35 one of the most successful
race cars of motorsport history so dad
ordered a second old-timer soapbox to
match his original 1938 Bentley
manufactured by the same person of
course these cars are basically built
the same way the real ones were out of
medium colors an aluminum body on a
wooden frame the d-type in the attention
to detail and dedication to these cars
is amazing and this is the man who
builds them punk bang :
from be borg in southern Germany his
artistry might not make him rich but he
doesn't mind it's all about the look in
kids eyes
[Music]
when I see that that makes me really
happy because that's what the cars are
actually made for I mean I like driving
him too but when children drive them and
really have a great time that's the
greatest joy for me it all started in
2012 there was a soapbox race in punk
Bunko nîmes village he'd been tinkering
with cars since he was
steam so he had no problem building his
own racer he didn't have the space to
keep it though so he sold it there was
such an onslaught of buyers that he
turned building soap boxes into a
regular thing I love any type of car
from before World War two they're all
beautiful
I have no favorites I like all my cars
the same he works as a foreign sales
agent but he's made quite a name for
himself with his classic soap box feed
stirs have a certain basic idea in my
head and then I start building and it
just happens it develops itself while
I'm building it there's no fixed concept
this is concept I know what the car is
supposed to look like when it's done and
then I make sure that's how it turns out
each of his soap boxes is one of a kind
the base is always a wooden board fixed
to a wooden frame then he makes the
aluminum body which can take weeks
sometimes months depending on the model
with all this attention to detail
doesn't it hurt to let go of his mobile
masterpieces yes every time but the
problem is I can't keep everything you
have to let it go sooner or later but
maybe this one can stay
chungbang Kunene completely rebuilt this
classic car only the chassis and motor
of the English 1930 standard had
remained
for Castanias he designed something
extra-special a soap box to practice
racing the idea was really to get a
sense of the experience even indoors the
car turned out beautifully it doesn't
have any wheels of course it runs on
roller self but it really helps me
practice for circuit races his daughters
are still only 10 and 11 years old and
it'll be a while before they're racing
for real easy with the smaller cars it's
more comfortable even if it's tighter
but here there is just so much more room
to be honest it depends on whether
Carlotta and I are having an argument
when we're fighting I prefer riding
alone and when we get along I like
riding with her but doesn't run fight
you by here if the two still have a soft
spot for cars like their dad when they
grow up
remains to be seen right now it's
looking highly likely
[Music]